bill burr is a good friend of the show
we love having a bond and he's a huge
sports fanatic the man lives and dies by
sports leave he's a big Red Sox fan as
well and he says from here amasses me
yeah he's from dude yeah yeah he's from
Newton and you know he's been with the
guys from Oakley and Anthony's I've been
on the show for years he's on the
travelling virus tour and as I was
saying he didn't show in Philadelphia
one time where he almost got booed
offstage and then for 15 minutes just
started berating the city of
Philadelphia to the point where he ended
up winning them over it's a YouTube
classic just go and type in bill burr
and Philadelphia and it's it's
definitely worth watching well he does a
thing on his website bill burr comm
where every Monday it's called the
Monday morning podcast and he records a
video of himself just talking about
anything some days he'll just feed your
brain and walk by one thing or the other
but this week you wanted to talk about
the LeBron James Fiasco but specifically
how do yorkers have been reacting to
LeBron James giving them the snub and
how many people are saying that LeBron
James was just intimidated to go to New
York City because it was too big of a
stage and he didn't want to he was too
scared of playing on the big stage let's
get to Bill burr the thing that [ __ ]
me the most was almost New York fans all
the Knick fans when LeBron didn't pick
New York we're trying to say that the
guy was afraid of New York and the big
stage what big stage are you talking
about Knicks fans what are you talking
about what Madison Square Garden you
ever won a championship since like 1973
so what is he afraid of what pressure is
there to carry the torch to not win it
for the 38th 39th and 40th year the
Celtics have 17 banners hanging from
their arena
all right so stand the down you don't
have a big stage you don't Madison
Square Garden oh it's a big stage for
I'm like what's that chick who can't
talk anymore who went on the road with
Frank's Liza Minnelli
when she goes down there and she does
her Fosse hands in front of all those
Elton John fans that's a mature of an
earnest of Draft when you go to a Knicks
game or a Rangers game for that matter
you know what that is that's from all
the open air from all those lack of
championship banners up there
Minneapolis Lakers disbanded in like the
early 60s have three month championships
in you okay
LeBron was not afraid to go there
there's no winning tradition in New York
City who's he afraid of [ __ ] I said
Nick given LeBron that if he goes to the
Miami Heat he wins down there
it's Dwyane Wade's team so you know no
one's gonna respect
LeBron if he wins down there look at
what the Yankees last 12 years
everybody from Kevin Brown to to a-rod
is piled on that team you guys invented
that to put your crying
as far as have more flags than you have
you ever been to San Antonio you haven't
I'm sick of people acting like New York
is a hard place to live you can make it
there you can make it anywhere from New
Jersey stop trying to claim him can we
have this guy back in check when he's
coming back because we have we have
every time he's at the Wilbur he's one
of our famous coming madness maybe only
behind Brian Regan my favorite comic
Brian Ricky's still my favorite but he's
he is a golden microphone here the touch
of rich show anytime on us to come in I
know you play a song at the end of the
Yankees game all right a big stage in
MSG interview
double digits with you flags first have
a little bit of perspective that's like
the twins talking